In order to get credit for this problem, all you have to do is hit the ship using that interphase
I just described before, but here are a few bonus questions if you're feeling adventurous.
Now, I warn you that these are pretty challenging so give them a try and feel free to discuss them
in the forums but you won't be graded on whether or not you can answer these questions.
The first bonus question is--what is the smallest angle α where
the cannonball still makes it over the iceberg?
Now you can imagine that at some point the angle α is going to be so small
if we keep decreasing it that no matter how hard we fire the cannon
it won't be able to reach over the iceberg.
I want you to tell me what's the smallest angle is where I'm still guaranteed to be able to
make it over the iceberg if I fire, however, with as much power as I want.